So, how can we tie this to our graph? Well, the train track is in one piece.
The train can't just jump from station to station, because it can't leave this
track. Similarly, all of the graphs that we've looked at so far are also in one
piece, with no breaks. When a graph is like this one, and has no brakes in it.
But, it's, rather, one piece connecting two points together. What can we say
about the range of that function? So, looking at this graph over here in
particular. What numbers can we say are in the range of this function? Does it
only contain the numbers, negative 8 and 4? Does it contain all of the integers
between negative 8 and 4? Does is span the entire interval from negative 8 to
4, but doesn't include those end points? Does it span that entire interval and
include the points negative 8 and 4? Or does it contain all the real numbers?
Please pick what you think is the best answer.